Kanye's new song is it me or no one
cares shees how you know he had a new
song but might be over musically for
kany no it's not I think he still has an
ability to Garner interest
through um
Antics but what do you always say they
have like a gravitational pull he has he
still has the gravitational pole but
musically he used to be able to stop the
planet and is a new song with Dirk and
was it party next door Ty dollar sign or
Tai dollar sign yeah and uh nothing like
I I I don't hear anybody bumping it now
we could make the argument the streaming
you know organizations are trying to
squash it and it's not getting uh radio
play but we don't listen to radio we're
just us and our friends people are not
using the audio online for their memes
like it's slow movement one two how do
you think the Arab world in the Middle
East World feels about all of
these
um almost like cancelled or like
lampooned celebrities running to them
for I know like nurturing and love once
they can't get it over here H like who
else I mean Tate
immediately right uh you know what I me
so it's like what happens you canceled
in America you just go out there and
then they're going to give you some
embrace because the celebity still has
some cache there and maybe they're not
as offended by the cancellations back
home but like do you think there's any
part of them that's like yo y'all just
coming here CU y'all can't get it like
that back home I think they're using
them too like all right this is cute for
now and then we'll eventually move on to
so it's mutual using I think that window
will probably close what do you mean by
that like for Middle Eastern countries
for embracing people because they're
just going to have so much clout that
like yo we don't need to take that's
what I'm say like y'all got the clout
you had every every every boxing
champion in history at the fight but
they paid for every boxing champion to
be that's fair but the money is no
option to that like they have unlimited
amount so Saud is UN limited amount of
money it doesn't have to like entertain
Kanye but it's like American celebrities
in Europe like older rap artists can
still tour crazy in Europe because they
don't see them that often so that like
they get more excited ah so there's a
novelty it's a novelty effect okay fair
they're always going to be able to get
that pop all right they're getting
everyone coming through I think that
window for who they once it just becomes
a place that you go now you know need to
rely on the people you can get which are
like the canell American or one the fast
I've ever seen is the Middle East I just
don't ever see it becoming a place that
everyone just
goes bro it's if you're in Europe it's
growing fast but it's still not
like people are still going to have some
Reserve where it's just like ah you know
but I don't know it's it's changing so
fast in three years it feels like it's
changed so much if it
honestly
now we're going to get geopolitical yeah
I think this is the reason why the Arab
Nations have not applied any
pressure or seemingly any pressure
towards Israel in the conflict right
now they will put out this forward-
facing support for the Palestinian
people but they ain't ready to bang and
I think it's because they're like listen
we do not want terrorism in this region
we want investment we want people coming
here for vacations we don't want this
area to be synonymous with danger murder
and killing we want this [__] settled so
Israel on the low I think they're basic
like Israel go in there get [__]
Hamas out of there handle all that [__]
right here so this thing can be squash
and everybody can kind of pour in with
the dollars because I think they tasted
it they tasted what it's like when
you're the bell of the ball and in
Europe people are going down to the
Emirates they're going down now Saudi
with these [__] events is looking
incredible there's all these new fights
that are already scheduled you have F1
races they're like listen we can't be
thought of as this disgusting Terror
area of the world and that will happen
if there's ongoing conflict handle it
yeah yeah and if they backed Palestine
this is going to go on
forever so I think they're they're
they're basically going
hey how quickly can we knock this [__]
out because we want to get back to
business we got to get Steve Harvey over
here immediately Steve Harvey loves I
there we go and if it's good enough for
Steve Harve good enough for me ex and
you know who doesn't care about that
Iran and you know who's not going to
Iran Americans ain't going to Iran I
don't know how many Europeans are going
to IR I don't know but they're the ones
who don't benefit from that tourism
don't benefit from the Western dollars
not even just Western dollars [__]
Eastern dollars everybody going in there
for vacation Etc they have no benefit so
they're like oh yeah let's [__] this up
y'all against us let's keep [__] it
up maybe even Russia comes in as well
but the other countries there who have
tasted the line tast of the enjoyment
tasted that capitalism I see I think
they're like hey shut this down as quick
as possible let's get back to business
as usual I think long term they see the
ability the potential to become a
superpower on like a global stage like
we are a force we got the money we got
people that'll do what you know what I
mean I don't know if they have the
numbers to be superpowered but I think
that they could be an economic
destination in a cultural destination in
a place where PE in a hub for
entertainment vacation business and
culture and it's like that can't happen
if people are scared to come here
because they're worried that they're
going to get uh [__] bomb explode in
a mailbox and they're going to die or
they're worried that somebody's going to
Chuck a rock at their wife for walking
around in a skirt so we need to make
this [__] feel very cool calm and and
and uh enjoyable for the West because
they tasted the dollars of the West
question um have they run out of oil or
they're running out of oil depends on
whom if we're talking about Saudi Arabia
no they have oil for what if we're
talking about Abu Dhabi Abu Dhabi still
has oil and and natural gas I believe
are they running out of boy Dubai has
none left ah Dubai Dubai is the best in
tourism so how long can they keep
overpaying before they run out I think
some country I heard this about Guth
they understood that their oil was
drying up so they had like a some like
firm or hedge fund or whatever take the
money we're making now and start
investing it and they invested in a ton
of apparently they own like a crazy
amount of the skyscrapers in London or
something like that so they are we're
running out of oil money but we're not
running out of money money run out of
oil but our money inv into other things
like don't they own uh who owns qar uhg
yeah yeah Paris St J like they've
invested in these incredibly lucrative
businesses so they're still generating
wealth and revenue but another part of
that would be creating a tourism
destination and it's been quite
effective and that's the idea of like
sports washing or whatever I'm just
wondering how long can they keep
overpaying cuz Sports washing is
overpaying it's overpaying like they're
not making their money back they're just
trying to it's PR move yeah it's it's a
big PR move so it's like how long can
they sustain that to before people like
fine overpaying this is a tricky thing
here because if the state owns the
operation they don't care about
profiting on it right they don't need to
Pro because they're not like Bob arum or
Don King has to profit because that's
where they pay their bills that's where
they pay their staff how they pay
everything if they just break even on a
fight right that's just their whatever
it is think about all the money that is
coming in from hotels all the money that
can come in for potential not only
sponsorships activities like people have
to eat while they're there right they're
going to go I don't even think they're
breaking even no but it's like a lost
lead like you know how Walmart would
sell toys for less than what they paid
for them because you know when you come
to Walmart you're not just buy buying
grer we're making our money elsewhere so
they have enough money to keep taking
the 50 million for a fighter or whatever
we have a trillions of dollars how about
this I'm just saying how long can they
keep doing that because every place else
can't do that because they're well
because other places aren't invested in
people looking at that as a possible
tourist destination so for example every
place well America don't need like
America like for example the America
isn't investing in this fight so people
come to America because people already
going to come to America but we need to
believe that Saudi is a place to even go
so according to this Google Search like
UAE has proven reserves equivalent to
299 times its annual consumption meaning
without net exports there will be 299
years of oil left but that's all of the
UAE and I and I think that's like oil
and natural gas like I think there's
some parts that still have natural gas
and then some part like abudabi is where
like the real money is in I was just
wondering how long can they continue
operating this way just to get people
like to change the vision in people's
minds where it's like oh you know what
it is safe to go how about look at like
this how much people who go to Disney
World will go think about like this how
much does um I don't know who cares
think about like this how much does uh
Tesla pay in advertising and commercials
zero Elon is their
Advertiser maybe Saudi isn't putting out
some crazy promotional campaign of come
to Saudi Arabia and spending $10 million
or $20 million across all these
different you know not even social media
Networks TV studios all this other [__]
and maybe they've gone all right instead
of spending $50 million that way why
don't we just spend $50 million on the
biggest fight we pay double but we'll
have all the eyeballs on what Saudi
Arabia is and we'll get maybe even more
benefit because people are actually
interested to come here and see what's
going on so maybe they're overpaying but
at the same time they might be paying
the same amount than they would pay to
advertise in a more traditional manner
for people to come to their country like
think about how stupid the commercials
are come to like whatever name a [__]
place exactly it's like that doesn't
work you know what works showing me that
they get the biggest [__] fight I
start going oh that might be a place to
hit up you talked about that show how's
what's the the oh The Real Housewives
got all the girls want to go [__] if you
don't think they paid um uh single old
[__] in New York show what's that
called sex SE SE in the city to do the
second movie in where where did they go
for they went to one Middle Eastern
country for the second movie like no
they paid crazy you they paid them [__]
hey they say hey make the whole thing
about here here's a check pay them
whatever the [__] you want we don't give
a [__] and then you have the four most
influential old white [__] that
influence all the other old white
[__] and younger white [__] now
they're going to go out
there I just feel like it takes a long
time to undo all of the negative press
America has put on
region that Reg 10 years Max yeah I
think 10 years Max before we're like you
know what it looks kind of lit though
yeah maybe no I think point it's like
how much money do they have to spend to
convince us it's okay for example like
when Taco Bell has like all them rats
eating a tacos while the place is closed
you take a week off Taco Bell you're
like Y what the [__] is going on with
Taco Bell you know what I mean but then
they put out the new Gordita Crunch and
you're like don't [__] with that you and
so like they have to again you know
basically dig them eles out of that hole
yeah and I'm just wondering which one
comes first like they going for it Comm
the people or they I think they have way
more money than time it's going to take
okay I
think I think we're already kind of
looking at it we're not fully being like
that looks lit but we're like I think
the tricky thing happens when
interesting this is why I think the
tricky thing happens when the places
that have built up these tourist
destinations that
haven't wrapped the tourism around
culture they've just wrapped it around
hey look at this crazy building or look
at this [__] arcade or look whatever
those can't offer anything when a newer
fancier tourist destination comes out
Italy's not going anywhere Greece is not
going anywhere Mexico is not going
anywhere because they offer thousands of
years of history and culture so if Saudi
is smart they'll look at the mistakes
that have been made and the successes
that have been made in the region and go
okay this this is what we have to avoid
and this is what we have to lean into if
I'm
Saudi or if I'm any of them I'm wrapping
around culture everything has to be
culture culture culture do that a little
bit but keep this good good you have a
good point they they do it with the hey
you know you can dress up where the head
scarf and take get pictures be on a
[__] camel and [__] like that but at
the same time it's like hey women can't
do this or you can't do that or you're
oppressed in this way it's like it's
hard to really wrap it around the
culture you got to you got to get people
addicted to the Commerce and once
they've become accustomed to their new
life they do not want to sacrifice it
and then once they don't want to
sacrifice it they're willing to make the
changes to continue this new
life and that is the game so the first
thing is get people addicted to the the
money and the success and driving the
nice cars and eating at the fanciest
restaurants and all your favorite
athletes coming over and then if they
feel that dip even a little bit you go
well people don't want to come here
because women can't drive they feel a
little bit then well let these [__]
Drive don't affect my money let them
Drive there's also maybe elements of the
culture we don't even know about like
what if they told you like hey we have
pyramids in Saudi Arabia you'd be like
may I have no idea yeah I have no idea
what's over there but this is like an
ancient country that has th generations
of culture that we might not know about
because they haven't pushed the culture
you know what I mean obviously us it's
tragic obviously what has happened to
Iraq and we are you know responsible for
that as a as you know America but there
is so much history in Iraq like this is
the birthplace of like Civilization like
imagine you could wrap that into the
tourism like going to see these [__]
ancient relics the ones that are still
there like you're like holy [__] this is
you're doing Rome again you're doing
Greece again it's in the Middle East
like to me that's exciting like I let's
go I want to see it and rap everything
around it you can do the fancy new
technological stuff just give me a
little feeling of the old stuff yeah you
know and yeah that was my only issue
with Dubai is like it just felt like
consumerism for consumerism sake and
they're the first ones yeah so they're
like okay how do we do this that I feel
doesn't last it it doesn't last when a
new thing pops up and I think that's
what Saudi is going they're going hey
the Emirates and the Saudis are friends
and everybody's cool and [__] but the
Saudi are still going okay so they
dumped a bunch of money into this and
they made this like technological Hub
and it's been amazing and successful and
it's a tourism destination people want
to see all this amazing fancy Stu but we
can also do that how else can we change
it how else can we improve it and I
think if I'm like if I'm the Emir or if
I'm the if I'm Saudi I'm making a
week of programming that you cannot miss
if you're part of like the jet Setter
crew the jet Setter crew often like
dictates culture like in New York for
example the end of summer it's Labor Day
people are in the Hamptons immediately
there's the US Open Labor Day and then
New York Fashion Week all within like 2
and a half weeks mhm if you're like a
wealthy person you're parking yourself
here for at least a week of that now if
you're not one of those super rich
people but you're one of us you're like
oh dude I want to go to some Fashion
Week parties or oh dude what's going on
for labor oh US Open it be sick to go
check out Uso you might try to do one of
those things how can you make one week
of events so imagine there's UFC fight
F1 and then there might be some cultural
like historical thing in the region
you're like yo I can hit all this [__]
in two weeks no I'm not saying this is
it but like UFC fight Andrew Schultz
Show is a weekend now if I'm some guy in
England I go bro I'd go to Dubai for the
[__] weekend I get to watch the UFC
fight in Abu Dhabi then Shelty the next
night like what's a week of that yeah
Saudi Arabia Fashion Week that's what
they got to do it up run it up dude but
but dead ass so it's like okay here's an
F1 race then there's a UFC fight then
there's another thing and now four of us
are sitting here going bro don't you
want to watch Izzy fight yeah yo Izzy
fighting and then we could also watch
the F1 [__] why we just go there for the
week the girls can go shopping over here
we just go yeah they got to get the
girls bro well that's that's they
focusing on the guys they got to get the
women the Russians got that unlock
though women so they're flying go go so
like the I thought it was like I thought
there were like freelance Pros out there
yeah you know what I mean like I thought
they were just like running their own
thing apparently it's like this is told
to me allegedly like russing russing
Mafia is tip to Russian mafia I don't
want to get killed by some Russians come
on I can't I can't do scary white but
basically like these Russian like Mafia
people like oligarchs basically are
flying in private jets full of Dimes and
then they just drop them off free range
and then if you go chat with them
they're like oh yeah like let's meet up
later like here's my number and then you
meet up and then there's a guy there
that's like all right here's what the
deal is and you can either leave or you
can stay but you got to pay I was saying
to get that [__] going you have to bring
the attractions to get the girls going
well that's the beauty I think girls
drive like where oh the girls are going
to be there that's when this is the
beauty of Fashion Week yeah the girls
all want to be at the Fashion events and
no girl is going to turn down the
opportunity to even go to a thing and if
you're a young hot chick you want to be
invented to all invented invited to all
the fashion so if you build cultural
tent poles around these events that
women really want to be at what what do
chick like that's the thing they haven't
been doing what do girls like bro
they're like like well Instagram
pictures how can you do what's the [__]
in Miami that's about to happen basil uh
our BAS oh God things way where you can
take pictures but here so here's the
thing that's how exactly can you do a
fashion show in a place that preaches
modesty for the women so if there's
going to be this fashion show where
you're going to have cleavage out you're
why I think that I don't know how much
so you have you have to find another way
what is another thing that these
beautiful women want to be at what a
beautiful woman like
dude a [__]
yeah that'll do it that's
we that's why New York is popping right
now the FL Studios I walk down the home
with this guy son it's crazy it's crazy
but what is it that's a good question
like how can they I mean F1 I think
women like but I think they don't like
the race they just like that is it is a
form of luxury it's like a yacht week or
something like that not women going it's
the women on the arms of a guy yeah
whereas fashion it's like chicks would
go if we go or not yes yeah so what what
is the
move what do girls like money girls like
money you could do that I around fashion
and like dressing up like Kentucky Derby
[__] what's the Derby Day or whatever
where girls get to wear them [__]
hats and all that that's that type ofu
that's
conservative the only problem is their
conservative dressing for women isn't uh
as fashion forward look like a
mummy it's all har bro exactly
everything GRS like is Haram what's up
with that yo low key that's why they had
to do it cuz they know what they like
and they got to stifle them desires bro
it wasn't always like that wasn't always
like that maybe Falcon why are they all
like Falcons out there you notice that
son I like a falcon back on a Falcons no
I just saw his picture saud's the Falcon
bro actually out
there bro you saw this [__] ched
a whole airplane saw and then just lined
it up with Falcons they already can fly
bro 80 of them they already fly you
don't even need to put them in a plane
so funny that is ax that's hilarious
that is a crazy don't even fly my boy
don't even fly we got you I got you put
him in coach though that's [__] up
this is where I was sitting my girl was
back here in the F Falcon so much I
don't know I saw Falcon almost die this
weekend actually this is a True Story
evil
times I think he talk about
ludicrous he did die did lud almost die
was coming down from the [__] he didn't
look comfortable at all bro you saw I
wouldn't be either that [__] was crazy
terrifying he let in the audience sing a
lot you know
that move at point I feel like he was
talking to the operator like no move I
need to get down serious please help me
out but no no I was at Medieval times
and they had a falcon come out in the
middle of the show and then the Falcon
flies around the whole thing and then it
flew into a net oh they still do that I
do remember that I remember that part
that [__] was impressive but your Falcon
didn't fly directly into a net and gets
stuck for a couple minutes flew into the
net got stuck and then everyone kind of
stopped cheering and then it flew down
and then like they caught it with the
Rope thing and then the Falcon was just
kind of on the ground for a little bit
that's what you loved about Medieval
Times up here we got it under control
fal's first day I don't like he was
struggling all the little nephews were
like what's up with the bird and then
immediately after they serve you a half
chicken like oh my God that is a little
crazy chicken though thank God that with
us we used had the big ass turkey leg or
whatever it was I'm glad they went
chicken yeah I have chicken it was
amazing bro I honestly I enjoyed it no
season no seasoning but they didn't have
season in medieval times yeah no you
remember it was just no seasoning on the
meat on the meat pause oh but like it
would it was like just I'm talking about
that tomato soup they was Ser oh dragons
blood you're talking about dragons BL
that's what they call they didn't have
tomatoes that's a new world thing but
they did have dragons blood back in
medieval time that's right tomatoes came
from sh I like how they cut cson just
say that's how things were back then
we could pay for spice H and say there
was no spice back there exactly no
knives and forks but this is [__] I
don't understand they used to rrap meat
in salt to preserve it and keep it like
for long distances and [__] use it in
the season and when you cooking it I
think it was Middle Eastern bro see they
were on season like on Long Journeys
they would just [__] cover the meat
and sot I don't think whites did that I
think whites did it I don't know bro I
don't know if whites were on the
preservation I was on the right [__]
yeah even the white yeah yeah yo mes is
on as [__] today y'all got to give it up
for B let give it up for B all those
Falcons have
passports we're back isn't that crazy oh
yeah that is actually a little wild the
UAA gives out Falcon passports what
that's that's crazy I like that isn't
that sick I like that oh that's a place
is not going to last they at the gate
there's enough [__] there's birds I
go the Customs anything to the clear bro
that's crazy so that guy not only got 80
seats he got 80 Falcon passports wow
that's so that's so rich that's awesome
holy [__] that's awesome yeah you got to
respect it anyway we got to go to
Medieval Times that's all crazy they
respect Falcons more than women ain't
that crazy yeah I know I know I don't
know they're both covered up not they
not no these Falcons they can't see oh
that's a little wow they got the head
covered no in that's crazy they're still
a little covered they got many they also
don't have hair but you got to cover the
hair Falcons got no hair only
feathers come on bro go to priz pi.com
use a promo code Schultz D match initial
entry of $1100 up to that $100 so you
put 100 they're going to match up to 100
exactly that's beautiful you said that
better than me now listen we in this
together we're Team okay we are teams go
to priz pick.com get that 100% deposit
match up to $100 wor the pro promo code
Schultz s CZ you got this okay now let's
get back to the show